well thank you very much I greatly
appreciated the opportunity to come and
talk with you and I have to tell you
after listening to that last talk i'm
really jealous of you all that you get
to stay here all week and have this kind
of opportunity for me this is a little
coming home because I actually graduated
from the school of organization and
management so Yale's business school is
school of public management and the
things that I learned in that class and
that the two-year program about
management and experiencing working
emotional intelligence how to present
how to construct a compelling argument
think strategically have been things
that I draw on have drawn on throughout
my career and I have to say that during
this 20 years I've also had some
opportunities to have some special kind
of sit back withdraw from the technical
environment i'm in and sit and have some
leadership and management training and i
am every time i've had one of those
opportunities found it incredibly
valuable because so often we're caught
up in our day-to-day and to have a
chance to step back and actually talk to
peers I'd learn from how they're
approaching different problems think
about things from a different angle can
be so incredibly valuable so I I think
you all are extremely fortunate to have
this week and I feel very fortunate to
get to share at least a small part of it
with you what I wanted to do is briefly
take you through some of what the global
the US Global Health Initiative is a
little bit of the context of how did the
u.s. government arrive at this and then
also some of what is it but what I want
to do is keep my talking on these points
sort of to a minimum to allow a maximum
amount of time for us to talk and
discuss what you're seeing what you see
is key issues and also what you've seen
from how the US government it has been
working with you in your countries in
ways that you think we can improve that
ways that you think we can be changing
the way we approach it to be more
efficient more effective more focused on
building the kind of capacity to take
forward your programs so that's where I
want to save the bulk of the time and I
hope please don't hesitate to ask
questions as we go but also will have a
lot of time at the end to be
discussing these different issues and my
double miked here is it too much now
okay I also was very struck by the
different problems that you've each
identified as areas that you want to go
forward and focus some of your attention
and recognizing that these are such
critical aspects of being able to
achieve the kind of health objectives
that and priorities that that your
governments have set and that the US
government is committed to helping to
support and so being able to go from the
generalized into the more specific seems
like a really valuable opportunity so
first why even a global health
initiative the US government has been
and continues to be highly committed to
global health in fact here you have a
quote from President Obama from last
year when he launched the Global Health
Initiative where he was not only talking
about the importance of achieving global
health today but even more that if we
want to be able to go forward we need to
be having sustainable programs so he
said we will not be successful in our
efforts to end deaths from AIDS malaria
and tuberculosis unless we do more to
improve health systems around the world
focus our efforts on child and maternal
health and ensure that best practices
drive the funding for these programs so
it was a program where he was really
taking the experiences and the
tremendous success of his predecessor
President Bush who had really up to the
game in terms of the levels of
investment he was putting through the US
government for for AIDS for malaria
through PEPFAR and PMI but taking it
even a step further and building on that
leadership by focusing it on how do we
ensure the capacity to go forward that
we're going to achieve these health we
can help support the achievement of
these targets today but be able to take
it forward so we've seen there's been
quite a big change over time in terms of
the level of health of investments
around the world to support your
programs this isn't even capturing the
changes within your own government
budgeting or the the large amounts of
bilateral fundings that are provided
through various groups
we've seen the advent of the Global Fund
we've seen the Gates Foundation come on
the scene and and really change some of
the funding flows we've seen Gabi and of
course things like PEPFAR and PMI and
out of this we've seen some real
improvements in health and I think the
the level of attention that the world
has brought over the last decade to
global health programs and working with
national counterparts to make a
difference has been quite extraordinary
but of course what comes as no surprise
to you is that the challenges are still
extremely significant and part of the
issue or probably the fundamental issue
with this challenges is we have a lot of
technical knowledge about how to tackle
each of these diseases there are a lot
of different sort of technical
strategies the survival medical approach
to these problems is actually fairly
well-known the biggest problem is the
underlying capacity to deliver all of
that no knowledge the management the
leadership throughout the system to
ensure that the priorities are set that
the focus is there that the human
resources for health are trained and in
place that the financial systems and the
flow of funds are following it that in
the end of the day we not only have
trained health workers we not only have
drugs we not only have facilities but we
actually have the right worker with the
right training in the right place at the
right time with the right drugs and
equipment and with a knowledgeable
population that is coming and demanding
those services and it's that combination
of events which is I think missing we
have pieces of it every program has very
many of the pieces in place it's when
they all need to come together to ensure
that at the end of the day that mother
is delivering in a facility that we
start to run into the difficulties and
in my experience that all really comes
down to the kind of management and
leadership which i think is is is what
you're here about and the role that you
play in your own countries
I would say to another kind of key
learning that we've had about why we're
not there and why these pieces aren't
all fitting together falls back on the
donors and how they've often engaged
with you where I know the US government
is is has been somewhat guilty of this
and many others as well of taking more
of a vertical approach and by taking a
vertical approach of looking at things
as a disease rather than looking at the
patient and their full needs and making
sure all of their needs are met we've
helped to fragment some of the programs
and some of the health systems further
and I think that that's been an
extremely important learning and so as
you look at as we look at sort of what
is the the leadership of the US
government what can we learn what can we
do differently how can we play an
optimal role in terms of engaging with
you and other other partners it's about
thinking about the value that's been
brought to the table by virtue of having
these disease specific goals of showing
success of showing the potential of what
we can achieve but at the same time
recognizing some of the transaction
costs we've created some of the burdens
and how can we improve upon that now as
the US has been exploring its commitment
on global health it's actually been a
relatively tough period to be doing that
in there are enormous financial
constraints I think every every country
including the u.s. is is having a tough
budget environment to work with in there
are some massive new areas of attention
for example climate change which is is
extremely urgent and needs to take a lot
of attention there's food security again
extremely urgent and in the area that we
all want to put more more attention more
dollars so there's a lot of very
important competing priorities and
global health really have the stage for
ten years for a decade and now there's a
lot of other a lot of other priorities
that are kind of crowding that stage
well the good news is for us is that the
US government went through all of that
thinking and the president secretary
clinton the the whole sort of our chain
of command is very very committed to
global health and continues to be
extremely committed and not only sees it
for the health factor but what's quite
extraordinary is they actually see it as
a fundamental part of the US government
approach to diplomacy and national
security so they've really elevated the
issue of development and in particular
global health within development I'm to
a much higher level than it's ever been
then it's ever been before frankly and
with that kind of leadership on our side
it means we can really approach and
tackle some of these problems in new and
different ways one issue that's
comfortable for is I think the
recognition that globalization has had
positives and negatives and I think most
of most of what we've seen in the press
has has highlighted some of the negative
effects of globalization the
interconnectedness and that when there's
a financial crisis in one country the
whole world feels the effects well
similarly clearly with health there's a
very significant global public good
element and when there's when there is a
disease it knows no borders but it goes
further than that it's also recognizing
that when you have a healthy happy
population when you have parents that
can see their children thriving you have
a much Stabler world you have a much
happier more peaceful world then when
you have parents who are watching their
children die before they reach the age
of 5 or 10 our countries that are
ravaged by disease and have no hope and
I think it's that understanding of the
humans of how each individual in the
population not how the national
government but how the people in the
country see happiness and see the
stability see the the rights of being a
human and having their children grow up
that I think is really driving some of
this this thinking and what they're
calling smart power is the US has a lot
of wealth it has a lot of voice
and it needs to use that very very
responsibly and it needs to use that
power in a very smart way and this is
part of the of the thinking driving that
I think well what's also gone on is the
US has looked at the stage of global
health is the understanding of that
there are different it's a humility
factor it's a recognition that to
achieve the kind of objectives that the
world wants to see in health there are a
lot of actors there are a lot of
different leaders in different areas
that have critical roles to play and
that bring different skills and the u.s.
is one of those actors but the u.s.
cannot do it all by itself I think
that's self-evident for everyone in this
room but that sometimes it gets lost in
the in the halls of Washington and
there's this recognition of how can we
be thinking about achieving this these
kind of goals of global health that
we'll talk about in a minute but first
and foremost recognizing the country
level partners and not just at the
national level but very importantly down
the chain to the district and probably
most importantly at the community level
recognizing the critical role that
governments play in setting priorities
in determining strategy in overseeing
what's being done in deciding the flows
of funds and ultimately in being
accountable to its population but also
recognizing that there are a number of
other players in every country that play
extremely important roles there's the
NGO community the FBO is the faith-based
organizations civil society down at the
grassroots level all of these groups
incredibly important roles not only in
sometimes delivering the services but
also in bringing to bear new skills in
assuring a level of transparency and
accountability in helping validate
whether those serve
is were indeed delivered or not in
raising the voice back to the popular of
the population back into complete the
chain the private sector lots of
discussion about what is the most
appropriate role of the private sector
bottom line is in many countries the
poorest families up to forty percent of
the funds on that they spend on health
are going into the private sector the
private sector is playing a very big
role in the provision of services and
the importance of ensuring that those
are quality services that are aligned
with best practices becomes extremely
important but you've also in a more
positive sense the private sector has a
lot of resources it has a lot of
different skills and being able to
harness some of those can become
tremendously valuable we can talk a
little bit but I've been very struck
about some of the examples of what I've
seen in countries of where for example
mining companies in in Africa who are
now recognizing that the cost to pay for
a rvs for a patient with a for a
employee with eight it's cheaper for
them then having to have a sick employee
and ultimately find a new person retrain
that person and get them up to speed on
the job very hard bit in economic
argument and yet incredibly valuable
because if it means the company is going
to start paying for a rvs we have a new
source of financing for what's one of
the most tricky problems of how do we
get more people on treatment so thinking
creatively about the different roles
that these different stakeholders play
in a country I think is a very important
thing and is a very big part of
government leadership there's also for
us the global partners and I know in
each of your countries you reflect on on
the the sometimes conflicting advice or
sometimes highly complementary and
supportive advice but also at our level
in working in at the global is the
different multi lots wh 0 the World Bank
what do they bring how can we work with
them how do we how do we identify
relative compared advantages the
bilaterals the government of Norway and
nether
in France and the g8 the Foundation's
like gates private sector and of course
this other cast of characters they're
playing roles both national and global
level and this recognition for us in the
US government that by aligning our goals
and collaborating more effectively with
this different groups we can actually
achieve much much more than if we try
and go at it alone we can actually be
mobilizing shared commitments and
engaging these different complementary
skills so it was that kind of thinking
that really formed some of the context
in which the work around defining this
this Global Health Initiative came into
play and as was mentioned that this GHI
inevitably bit confusing with gh li and
GHI but the difference there is a
difference a 63 billion dollar won the
appeal had its way we might reverse that
but so so what we'll do it tuck take you
a little bit through what is G H I it is
this six year commitment for 63 billion
dollars to support a lot of different
health outcomes so it's really thinking
not so much about the disease focus but
more about if a patient walks into a
clinic what are the needs that they have
what are the services that they require
we'll talk a little bit about some of
the principles that are embedded in GHI
which i think is some of the most
exciting aspects of it because that's
the what's different how do we work
differently and I think have potential
to work much much more effectively
smarter so first is the issue of the
targets so GHI is building on is a
recognition of and is building on the
successes of PEPFAR of PMI of the work
that USAID and others have done in in
MCH so it's building on that what's
come before it it's not changed it's not
walking away from it it's building on it
it's recognizing pepfar did an
extraordinary thing it fundamentally
changed the amount of resources and the
attention of the American population and
of our Congress and of our
administration towards some global
health targets and that's why it
continues to build and set even more
ambitious targets in the domain of
hiv/aids and similarly in the domain of
malaria where we have the president's
malaria initiative but what I think is
truly exciting is GHI is all about
saving more lives and so in addition to
ambitious targets for AIDS malaria TB
you also have ambitious targets for
maternal health and child health and
neglected tropical diseases and family
planning and nutrition so it's really
broadening out to be even more effective
in terms of what we can achieve and to
be thinking more about the person the
person with hiv/aids who goes into a
clinic who has more needs than just
having her ARVs she may be pregnant and
what a tragedy for her to be given the
hope of having a rvs and then have her
die in childbirth or have her newborn
die so this is what I think is probably
the most exciting part it's this basket
it's this balanced basket that's really
looking at the holistic needs in
addition though GHI is looking about how
do you achieve those targets and first
and foremost and as you saw in President
Obama's quote it's about doing it in a
sustainable way we don't want to just
receive these target Eve sort of some of
these targets or support you to achieve
these targets and then five years down
the line have a decline we want to
ensure that these targets can be a
sustained and built upon and that
becomes an important question about how
do you do it right you can have
campaigns you can fly and fleet the
volunteers and achieve a lot in the
short term
but when the volunteers go home if you
don't have an investment in the systems
which you all are running what do you
have left so I think that's the that's
the biggest change in this thinking is
how do we ensure that we not only
achieve those targets but do it in a
sustainable way that's about building
capacity and hence the first principle
supporting greater country ownership and
I'm looking forward to hearing many of
your thoughts about how do we do it
country ownership is one of those
buzzwords that everyone likes to throw
around that makes it sound good but what
is the difference in terms of how we do
business on the ground to best achieve
it recognizing the constraints that you
face the constraints that we face
because ultimately I have to go to my
Congress and report how that money was
used so there are certain constraints
that I'm going to face if I want to see
more money in the future but to get to
that that objective second is
implementing a woman and girl centered
approach why a woman a girl centered
approach get lots of audiences for all
the men raise their hand saying don't
the men matter and of course the men
matter fact the men always get there
first so I'm not so worried about them
but with the women and girls centered
approach it's really a recognition of
oftentimes the women have are the most
marginalized have the least voice and
have some of their some of the biggest
health needs health needs that are unmet
in addition to the woman in enough
herself of course is the very special
role that she plays in terms of the
health of her family and of her
community because it's the woman that
makes a decision to seek preventive care
it's the woman that makes the
nutritional decisions in the family in
most cases and so she has a very special
role that has a hugely contributing
factor to the overall health in the
country third is this issue of
coordination collaboration integration
so this recognition of how we work with
others is critically important if we
want to be at
these goals how we work with with you
how we work with other partners in
country or globally and also quite
frankly how we work within the US
government because there are different
parts of the US government and it's in
critically important for us in the
government if we want to work smarter
more efficiently and effectively to be
thinking strategically about you know
what is the unique skills that CDC
brings versus USAID versus the NIH and
its fogarty program what are those
different skills and how do we use them
to best effect building sustainability
so this issue of how do we build
capacity how do we build health systems
and I think what we'll have to come back
to what's important here is and I think
as you all know very well but has been
has been a point of confusion in the
past health systems are never an end in
and of themselves health systems are
means to an end but we've already gone
through the period of the 90s where
somehow health systems became the end
point and I know the World Bank had a
lot of learning around this l systems
became the end and there was counting
how many people trained counting how
many facilities built but that point
that I said in the beginning of whether
you actually had those trained health
workers in the right facility with the
drugs they needed with a population and
ultimately delivering the service wasn't
captured so coming back to that how do
you do health systems in a way that's
meaningful and that change it that
results in in actual changes in in
health improving metrics monitoring and
evaluation will come back to that Mike
noted we were we were laughing because
Betsy was saying how when Mike was
talking about later in your program were
you're really talking about monitoring
evaluation and all of this I have been
saying earlier this morning that this is
an area where we in the US government
have a lot of thinking to do and we can
sort of i'm sure you all know it from
the number of indicators that you have
to respond on and all the rest and it's
something we can i'd like to talk about
some more
and last is promoting research and
innovation to identify what works so
what does that all add up to what is new
about GHI I think for to start with
recognition that all of the principles I
just laid out or what in the u.s.
there's an expression that's called
motherhood and apple pie which means
everyone knows that's what you should do
I don't think anything that was on that
previous slide would be a surprise to
anyone in this room the issue is though
we're not always doing it and we're
certainly not doing it consistently
we're certainly not doing it with a
dedicated focus we're certainly not
doing it explicitly some of the
trade-off decisions you have to make
about achieving you know even a target
faster or achieving it but achieving it
a little slower while building capacity
those kind of really tough choices have
always been kind of under the table and
now we're trying to raise them into the
day of you know the sunlight say let's
make some explicit decisions here of how
we approach these so what's new is this
very explicit recognition that we need
to collaborate for impact at the that we
need to be working better more
effectively more align greater alignment
with you your governments other partners
in your countries and with our very
scorable health partners doing more of
what works well part of the challenge
there is what works do we have the
evidence base in all cases about what
works what doesn't especially when it
comes to these issues of health systems
as I said we have a lot of evidence
actually on the on the biomedical side
of things but when it comes to
behavioral change when it comes to
building more of a community based
platform the amount of evidence actually
in these areas is pretty thin when it
even comes to exciting innovations like
performance-based performance based
financing which Rwanda is playing an
extremely important role in which I
noticed a couple of of your governments
are looking at we have some great
evidence thankfully from Rwanda who did
some really important evaluation work
around it but that's one country and we
need more so this issue of let's do what
works let's not do what doesn't work and
let's admit which is which and have the
evidence base to support it is a really
critical issue and I know in there the
importance of a leader my my boss at
USAID the new administrator is dr. Rajiv
Shah who's who's amazing and an
incredibly compelling speaker I'm very
effective at bringing people along but
he looks at the culture of people not
being willing to admit what doesn't work
which I'm sure anybody in politic
environment we certainly have it in the
US government I'm sure you all face it
you never want to admit what doesn't
work and yet there's so much learning in
what doesn't work there's so much
learning and saying you know we finally
got here but it took us four attempts
here's the first three attempts and why
they didn't get us where we needed to go
and what we learned and how we corrected
and then how we use that to apply going
forward and off times that stuff just
gets lost its swept under the table and
nobody ever acknowledges it so he keeps
threatening staff at USAID that he wants
to hold a failure conference and we keep
saying well can change the title at
least you know a great idea but i'm not
sure failure conference is gonna get
green attendance but home a failure
conference effectively where it's about
having people come in and celebrating
acknowledging the value of the kind of
work that they've done where it didn't
ultimately get them where they wanted to
go but where there was the explicit
learning behind it and how that learning
then informed what we did next so that
we were just doing the same mistake over
and over hopefully but instead kind of
taking it building on it and
incorporating it into our strategic
thinking going forward and start trying
to change the culture in my organization
in other places so that that becomes a
positive rather than currently where
nobody wants to admit that they didn't
achieve what they thought they were
going to achieve and i have to tell you
we're even getting that message from our
congress
so the people that ultimately decide you
know how much what are the priorities
that the US government will be
supporting in terms of our funding
support and the Appropriations and what
not saying we want to know what didn't
work we want to make sure that you're
not just repeating bad mistakes over and
over and by acknowledging what isn't
working you actually give us some
confidence that you're paying attention
you're collecting this data and you're
making wise decisions going forward what
else is new in this business model is
this expanding the platforms so this
issue of of Health System strengthening
capacity building one of the big pieces
of that is is integration and I know in
Africa in particular many many countries
had a programs you know started your
health programs which were around an
integration platform was when someone
walked in a primary care facility they
had all their services and overtime in
part because of the way donors have been
very focused on achieving specific goals
off times that's been fragmented out so
now a mother might walk into a facility
and be told sorry but this is just the
hiv/aids facility if you want antenatal
care or obstetric care you need to go
down the road or into the village or
into the district especially if it's
emergency care and the mother may not
have that option she may there may be a
lot of hitting constraints she may not
have the bus fare or the ability to
assure the food for her family and for
herself while she takes that extra time
to go off and so thinking about them
again not treating the disease but
treating the patient and their full set
of needs and this issue about how can we
really be thinking much more about this
integrated platform and kind of coming
back to that original logic which is
fortunately still in place since many
countries
the issue of women and girls which I was
explaining a little bit of that of the
health rationale behind but what does it
mean in this sort of new business model
to focus on women and girls well when
Peter was talking about sort of where
there can be a passion and using that
passion with your technical knowledge
for for really driving forward in your
leadership this is secretary Clinton's
passion is women and girls empowering
women and girls meeting the needs of
women and girls really changing that
picture is secretary Clinton's passion
and because of her incredible leadership
you can bet everyone is making sure that
this is something that we're really
thinking about in new creative ways so
it's an incredibly exciting opportunity
how do we tackle what's the age old
problem of not only addressing the
health needs but by trying to address
health needs when needs to be thinking
about the determine the social cultural
determinants economic determinants that
ultimately are behind whether or not she
can even access the service or whether
she's had a voice in the design of the
service to assure it makes her knee it
meets her needs and thinking creatively
about how do we systematically remove
some of those barriers and this is an
area where the US government is really
excited to learn with countries who are
pushing that frontier to see how do you
do it what does it really mean on the
ground and then sharing that with others
we talked about innovating for results
the innovation doesn't come from
Washington or London there's incredible
innovations going on in each of your
countries and every time I'm you know
I've been a struck when I'm down in the
district and there's some amazingly
clever approach to some problem and yet
the country doesn't even know it
sometimes it doesn't even make it out of
the sort of district environment I mean
I was in I was at a recent meeting where
they had it's about two years ago in
Zambia
and they had the district manager who
had come up with this really really
clever way of bringing people in you
know what as he said is the food issue
so he started cooking to actually feed
the clients that were coming to him to
make sure that it wasn't food that was
acting as a barrier for people coming to
get health services there was a whole
issue about motivation and incentives
and he didn't actually have the budget
to be doing something like performance
based financing so he was looking at
other forms of an oven trinsic reward of
how do you make a special recognition
for the villages under his district
authority to recognize who was doing
what and acknowledge it and get some
extra credit around it huge impact just
something as simple as recognizing
individual motivation making a plaque
and having an award ceremony and when
this this district manager was brought
up to be part of a global conference
which had a whole delegation of Zambians
and he was sharing these ideas and it
was it was amazing and it was really
something that was sort of a level of
innovation and leadership that hadn't
been surfaced as much and Zambia now is
learning from that district learning
from some other places and thinking
about how can they go forward with
something like performance based
financing recognizing these issues of
motivation and all the rest and so it's
trying to kind of my view innovation and
the job of an entity like the US
government is working with you to
identify where you are already you or
someone in your country or is pushing
the envelope what can we learn from
Ethiopia's you know the health extension
workers amazing program many countries
are facing the same kind of problems a
lot of learning in there what can we
take from from Rwanda results-based for
performance-based financing program has
had extraordinary impact in terms of the
the supply of services the way health
workers are treating the patients that
come to them because now it's you know
the patients don't come there's no
reward how can we learn from what each
of you and other countries are doing
where you're each kind of taking an
innovative approach and surface and then
ensure that there's the data
behind it and then share that broadly
what did you do why were you motivated
to do it how did it work out what's the
data to substantiate it what didn't work
how did you handle the realities of the
life which are often forgotten by the
Washington folks of the unions how can
you do PBF where you're changing the
salary structure of health workers when
you have to deal with all the teachers
and what this means on the education
side of the argument all of these sort
of really really practical issues which
when you're in the country you've dealt
with but often get forgotten when you
look at the sort of more academic our
models of these things and that's the
real value so what we want to be doing
is really helping to identify those
things helping to provide the support to
get the evidence behind it and then then
providing the forest so that you can
exchange your own learning amongst each
other and we can learn while you're
doing it and that that's what we think
of as key innovation but they
importantly on the Omni M&E side is the
expression that you have in the business
sector which is you can't manage what
you can't measure and so we put a lot of
weight on that but at the same time is
the problem we have now in public health
which is we're measuring everything much
of which we're not needing to manage so
we've actually overloaded the systems
with all of these demands for the
planning and the reporting and every
donor has a slightly different indicator
just different enough that it requires
another whole exercise to collect it and
the problem with all of those indicators
means that people aren't actually
focusing on the ones that are really
meaningful you don't have the time we
don't at the time you know our staff in
country are their number one complaint
in fact is the incredible burden placed
on them never mind you the burden placed
on them in terms of the reporting and
planning requirements behind PEPFAR
behind PMI behind all of these separate
programs and that's where something for
us like GHI allows us to do some
reflection and
learning about not only what we talked
to you about but how we think about it
ourselves and that's where this dialogue
becomes very important and hearing which
you have to say so that we can ensure
that the way we're approaching these
programs is smarter so how does G H I
work in general for the u.s. government
it's about a whole of government so this
issue of recognizing what different
parts of the government can bring to the
table and really maximizing that value
integrating how we work focusing on
creating greater country level capacity
so that's the country ownership and the
system's recognizing that we're building
on existing programs and plans so we're
not trying to duplicate anything we have
to look at for example the planning and
reporting that's already there already
alone overloading the system before we
think about how can we actually do GHI
it's funny in the u.s. they have the the
pet fires are called in Washington the
cops I'm not even sure what it stands
for but it's the cops and so then when
the malaria program came along they were
the mops and then there's another one
another hope reporting requirement that
comes from our finance group which they
call the F ops so when we started
talking about GHI every field staff was
like please tell us you're not going to
create the GOP's because we just can't
survive and that's been heard loud and
clear up so thinking about that building
on these existing plans programs and
seeing how can we be smarter more
rationalized in the approach how do we
coordinate better how do we look at the
existing agreements that are set up and
they work with your your national plans
your nationally set priorities and
targets to take it forward and above
above all else not trying to create some
sort of vertical program not trying to
create something which is the US
government does it by itself but really
collaborating much more closely on the
operational plans
a lot of thinking is going into this and
is still going into this GHI and this 63
billion will be implemented in all
countries all 80 plus countries where
the US government has investments in
health so GHI is about every country
that we're working in and many of the
programs have already started to take on
board some of these principles that
we've that have highlighted and started
to look at how their program can be
tweaked and changed to better address
that but part of what we want to do is
go faster and harder in terms of making
progress towards change and as you all
know changing how you do business is
really hard in a political environment
in a government environment so in
addition to the the real meat of this
which is G H I implemented everywhere
what we've done is set up this program
called GHI plus and I know Rwanda in
Ethiopia are both GHI plus countries but
the objective in these plus countries is
to have some additional technical
assistance some additional management
focus so for example my attention in
particular to see how can we really
accelerate the implementation of GHI how
can we when we talk about country
ownership let's not talk about it
vaguely let's sit down in starting with
these first eight countries which are
the GHI plus countries and really get
down into the details of what does that
mean in terms of how we program our
funds in your country when we talk about
a woman and girl centred approach let's
talk reality of in different country
context given the socio-political
environment in that country what makes
sense what are the practical steps that
can be done what can we learn from that
and how do we share that so part of
what's going on with these plus
countries is really some people refer to
it almost as a intensified Learning Lab
that these countries really help us push
a little further a little faster and
then allow us to share all of that with
all 80 countries so everyone can benefit
from their learning the the way the plus
country
is where chosen was not a good or a bad
or a priority or non priority it was
really all about where did we think
there wasn't a good opportunity for
learning so the first question there was
where is the government and other
national partners and the the team on
the ground the usg team on the ground
want to be a partner in this effort
where was it a priority for them that
they were interested in this kind of
learning responsibility and sharing this
information with others and helping
provide that kind of leadership role so
that became the first question then in
addition we looked at what were some of
the different things going on that might
be of real value so where did we have
the different programs you know big
PEPFAR PMI MCH malaria malaria TB types
of programs that we could be learning
from and the integration issue where
were there other sectoral programs that
the US government was investing in so
for example there's a whole Feed the
Future initiative which is about food
security so you want to make sure we
have some countries which were doing
feed the future and could be a GHI plus
because where those two programs come
together is nutrition and the really
exciting learning that can do going on
in nutrition about how do you get the
agricultural and trade guys to be
thinking about nutrition as an endpoint
to get them to adopt a goal like
stunting as a measure of whether they're
achieving their your food security goals
and conversely maybe get the health
group to adopt goals like you know is
there a basket of does a typical family
have access to affordable basket of
dairy products so you're checking out
food diversity so trying to get those
crossovers across the different sectors
I'm similarly looking at governance type
of programs because ultimately this
issue of a woman and girl centred
approach isn't just a health one it's
about the the political issues
governance empowerment of woman which
goes way beyond the health sector so
looking for those kind of crossovers
also looking globally so where were
there some really interesting learning
opportunities globally like I hp+ the
International Health Partnership Plus
which many
bilaterals and multilaterals are part of
and it's about how can they harmonize
and a line better the way that they're
doing business with governments and we
want to see how can the u.s. learn from
that or the health system strengthening
platform that the Global Fund and the
World Bank and gavi are exploring right
now what can we learn from that to see
how we do business so those were the
kind of factors that were used in terms
of identifying this first set of plus
countries and they'll be I think the
intentions have a second round of plus
countries around 2013 but then working
with these countries but working with
all 80 countries what we're trying to do
in GHI is actually just make the space
for the effective planning on the ground
so it's not about you know a dark room
in Washington where people are defining
this is what you will do this is how it
will all look but rather saying what
we're doing is defining the operational
plan with the country teams on the
ground so there's already been a visit
to Kenya a visit last week to Nepal to
start working with the country teams
meeting with national counterparts
government and others to kind of get a
feel for how should we structure these
things and then those will be form the
basis for the guidelines that are sent
to to all countries in fact when I left
Washington that I think they were in the
midst of trying to plan for me to be
going to Ethiopia very shortly
potentially next week and so again
taking forward that conversation country
by country so that we're learning at by
talking with the countries and designing
around that what they're thinking that
the plan might look like is GHI has
these global targets that I outlined
earlier the first order of business is
having these global targets but having
those translated down to the national
level so every country has its national
targets from its plants and looking at
what are those targets if there's room
for dialogue because if the usg comes in
and says you know if we provide extra
support do you think you might make this
target a little more ambitious that we
can help you achieving it but that
ultimately has to be a nationally known
target and that that should be set the
where are we going question then once we
know where we are going within the
country looking at the existing plans so
starting with the national plan and
national strategies but also looking at
all of these usg plans that exist and
having a sense of what are other donors
and partners doing so where are there
gaps versus where there are a lot of
players to then think effectively of if
this is where we're going and this is
what we've got on the table right now
and where we are what needs to be
changed where aren't we going to get
because of the existing plans aren't
adequate where do we think you know
where's the government and other
partners and the US team think we need
to push on the frontier and then that's
how we want to be driving forward the
plan more okay building on these
existing plans and lastly and
particularly for the plus countries but
it's something we would support in every
country is out of that picture is having
a learning agenda fall out so you
they'll be monitoring and we're trying
to streamline all the monitoring and
planning that's going on but there's
some really valuable learning that we
want to capture so of that area that was
identified as the key areas to be really
pushing shaping piloting something new
or scaling up something that everyone's
very excited about which of those areas
would be really valuable to have some
extra learn what we want to make sure we
have the baseline data so we know where
we are and then we can tell where we got
where we want to have a really well
designed for purpose type of of study
whether it's the super rigorous
evaluation or something that's lighter
more timely more focused depending on
what the issue is and so that we can
focus some of this additional technical
assistance and management tension on
capturing those things so at the end of
the day we have these lessons learned
that can be shared more broadly across
the world so that would be what it would
the plans overall would look like in the
longer term what we hope to have is one
ghi plan
instead of the cop and the mop and the F
up and all of these other things we
would have put one plan that kind of
captures all of that those different
pieces but it'll take us a while to get
there as I'm sure you can imagine so
going forward I think there's a lot of
room to be working together in a new and
i think a more higher impact way and
we're very excited to have that dialogue
and hear what you have to say and i'm
pretty excited to be here now so i can
take some of this back with me as we're
in this very active period of thinking
learning and trying to design i
identified a couple of topics that i'm
interested in hearing about but i'm very
happy to talk about anything with you
but one is how can the u.s. better
support country ownership what does that
really mean in your country context some
discussion around the respective roles
within your country's what you see from
other countries but about how to really
maximize what the government brings to
the table with what NGOs FBOs the
private sector civil society the
communities themselves what the roles
can be what they are now and what you
think they can be in terms of really
achieving your targets and then how can
we help you to achieve that to help
strengthen some of that capacity some
sharing of some of the new ideas to old
problems and the issue about how do we
make sure we're getting that evidence
base to substantiate what we're really
excited about and to share it in a more
meaningful way so that your governments
have the data necessary so your Minister
of Finance has the data necessary to
make a big decision about allocating
resources to support a scale-up if
that's appropriate from your decision so
other governments are in a position to
know what you've done why how and what
the impact was and we have a compelling
argument and frankly so that donor
partners like the US and others can be
learning from it and aligning our
funding in an appropriate way and then
the last big question I put down was how
do we be how are we strengthening
systems while at the same time we're
really increasing the focus and the
count ability for results and frankly I
don't even talk outcomes impact
intermediate outcomes outputs I mean the
conversation can go on forever and I've
had it forever with the World Bank in wh
0 so I just want to talk results and we
can define what those results mean but
how are we really assuring that we are
achieving the the right kind of service
delivery to the right population to
achieve the kind of health impact that
you've set his priorities so I'll stop
there and and then we can just open it
up for discussion